[Music]
none of us want a learning environment
where we feel threatened so for example
I don't want to have to be learning in
an environment where there are people
with somebody whatever you call them
assault rifles around me right I don't
want to be learning in an environment
where I have somebody who's openly
misogynistic and yelling misogynistic
slurs at me all the time so all of us
want safe spaces for learning that's not
unusual it's not a bad thing the
question is where do we put the borders
on that and in some circumstances in
universities we've reached the point
where we're so so dedicated to the idea
of making sure everybody feels
absolutely comfortable that we've shut
down some people's ability to speak and
to think and to go beyond where comfort
zones may be and that's where it becomes
a real problem so it is not the case
that universities should be places where
you feel comfortable all the time
intellectually we're supposed to be
uncomfortable that's how we grow as one
of my graduate school professors said to
me if you haven't changed your mind
lately how do you know it's working and
I thought that was a really good way to
think about it I was he said that to me
when I was stuck in a particular idea
and I wasn't budging and he thought I
was being obstinate and I was and I
started thinking well maybe changing
your mind isn't a bad thing but what's
happening on a lot of university
campuses this is the notion you come
with your pre-existing beliefs about
your identity about the world and no
one's supposed to question that and I
think that's very problematic you know
for example people say well we don't
want right-wing people on campus I do I
want everybody on campus I want
everybody having the same educational
opportunities and I want the opportunity
to actually have real conversations
about different points of view getting
them out in the open airing them being
able to have conversations arguments
thinking about data thinking about
evidence thinking about histories of
justice it allows us to have those
conversations in a way that I think has
integrity and honesty and gets us
somewhere so if people have the attitude
you know some people are allowed in
campus some people are not some people
are allowed to speak some people are not
that doesn't really get us forward
certainly it is the case we should not
allow people to openly abuse each other
verbally in way
that are profound so for example using
n-word for example but beyond that I
think we have to have a lot of
generosity in terms of allowing people
to air ideas and giving everybody time
to do that so that we can have
meaningful education
so this oversimplification of history
this sort of idea of everybody is good
or everybody is evil as opposed to there
are some people who are kind of nasty
but did some useful work there some
people are good but did some terrible
things trying to inject some of that
subtlety and thinking historically
thinking empirically would be a heck of
a lot better than doing simplistic
identity politics where everybody gets
devil horns or an Angels halo and you
account for that based on current ideas
of who what's a good identity what's a
bad identity it's not a good way to
think
[Music]
you